is Scott bachula about to appear in
strange new
worlds run our away welcome to S Che
your SciFi TV and move a
[Music]
channel this has been rumored for a
couple of years now actually that Scott
bachula would return to Star Trek as
Captain Jonathan Archer or Admiral
Jonathan Archer re Admiral Jonathan
Archer retired Admiral Jon I don't
really care but he would be back in Star
Trek in some form when strange new
worlds was actually announced over three
years ago now it was rumored very
quickly that Scott bachula would be
willing to make a return now that seemed
a little unlikely because where the time
frame is set for Strange New World Scott
back would have to be about 130 or
something and actually his car character
in Canon is supposed to have died around
15 years
before but I argued in a previous video
or I discussed this that actually that
doesn't mean they couldn't have some
sort of flashback episode maybe we see a
slightly younger Pike 15 years before in
a flashback meeting Archer you know in
the last couple of years of his life
there's no reason why that couldn't
happen now obviously they could also
just do some sort of time travel thing
you know at the end of the day there was
a whole storyline in Enterprise about
Scott beula's Jonathan Archer jumping
through time so maybe he just jumps
Through Time onto the Enterprise there's
no reason why not and to be honest
strange new worlds even though it's been
brilliantly executed let's not kid
ourselves that it's all that bothered
about Canon really or all that bothered
about doing crazy storylines that make
very little sense to do a musical or
something else you know at the end of
the day they do try to throw in a bit of
science here and there to make it still
science fiction but they're not that
bothered if they were that bothered
there were several episodes that
wouldn't have happened in the last
season in
[Music]
particular so what am I hearing why am I
suspecting that this might actually
about to happen well I've spoken to a
couple of sources that are reasonably
close and they've said look even though
there were a lot of rumors that Strange
New World season 3 might not even happen
because there are Executives over at
Paramount that actually do want to pull
a full reset on Star Trek they want to
pull back from what's been done at the
moment and I am talking in other videos
about how Paramount might actually be up
for sale in the next 12 months and there
is certain preparation work being done
towards that goal now those decisions
are business decisions and even though
they don't seem to have been made yet
because they do seem very dependent on
sort of restructuring some Finance in
the next few years and well really the
stockholders me to make a decision as
well it does mean that there's certain
things with Star Trek and other big
Paramount projects that might be in the
air a little bit over the next few years
there are also a lot of Executives at
Paramount that don't like what Alex
curtzman has done with certain elements
of St treack and they would like it to
change now a lot of those changes are
happening we are we've already seen a
bit of a curtzman reset with a lot of
Star Trek we've seen Star Trek return
back to something that we recognize as
trekkies as Star
Trek we haven't had any more of the
horrific
cock-ups that happened in Discovery
season 1 that really turned a lot of
Star Trek fans off so there is a lot of
uncertainty regarding Star Trek moving
forward but what we are sure of is that
the negative side of Executives over at
Paramount didn't win the argument and
Star Trek season 3 of strange new worlds
has started production they will be
filming in the next few days and we will
get that series on our screens before we
know it so why do I think Jonathan
Archer might actually appear well
speaking to one of my sources over at
secret hideout they have been absolutely
desperate to do the next big crossover
the viewing figures for strange new
worlds were on the whole quite
disappointing they really did think
after Picard season 3 that the viewing
figures would have kicked on and that
they'd have got on for example the
Neilon list which is the overall top 10
of streaming shows each week they
thought they would get on that more
often than than they did I think strange
new Will's got it maybe twice basically
they saw big bumps around the lower deck
crossover episode and then again with
the musical now I've actually said to
you a few times before a lot of the
musical stuff was simply because people
were talking about it so they watched it
just to see really if they were going to
hate it as much as I did or if they were
going to love it as much as I know a lot
of Star Trek fans did so there was a big
spike I was fascinated to watch it even
though I was not looking forward to it
so Executives and people like Goldman
over at Star Trek are already looking
for that next big crossover that next
big thing that will get tongues wagging
and one of the things that I'm being
told they are desperately trying to do
and they have a script for but
apparently Scott buul hasn't actually
agreed to is for Jonathan Archer to
appear in season three of strange new
worlds now
I'm filming's already started so why do
I say Scott bachula may not have
actually agreed to this I have to admit
I have three different sources that tell
me these bits of information one has
said that the script was written but
Scott Baul refused to do it and pulled
out one said that the script was written
Scott bacular agreed and he's actually
filming in the next eight weeks and that
episode will be around the fourth or
fifth episode of the season I've got a
third Source that's basically said the
script is written Scott bachula was up
for it but they couldn't agree on money
so it didn't get agreed and he won't be
doing it what do I think is going on I
think Scott bachula is going to appear
in Star Trek strange new worlds but I
think they're trying to throw people
like Sidetrack off the track I think
they're possibly spreading a few
different room rumors to see which one
floats and just to confuse us YouTubers
and US fans as much as possible I think
we'll probably hear a few more rumors
about this and we'll see something maybe
even more definite in the runup to the
actual series being
released could they get Scott bachula
into film an episode and it be a secret
yeah they could to be honest they kept
the musical secret and they kept a few
of the other things from Strange New
World season 2 as secret until only a
few weeks before they were released at
the end of the day it's relatively easy
to keep something a secret if it's
filmed on a Sound Stage it's much harder
if you're going to record things out and
about on location because people with
big cameras and take the photos on the
same stage unless a crew member leaks it
or somebody says something wrong in an
interview we're not going to find out
the rumors Bounce Around partly to keep
interest alive but also partly because
agents and things like this do talk and
to be honest the source that I actually
believe on this does work on the agent
side of things he has heard that yes the
script was written Scott beula was
interested and he will be filming an
episode for strange new worlds season 3
so we can all get a little bit excited
with a big pinch of salt because we
don't know for certain if this is going
to happen or not so let's wait and see
which rumor is actually true I can't
wait because actually I loved Enterprise
I'm one of those people that thought it
was getting much much better and I
genuinely believe if they'd have done
the modifications to the Enterprise NX
and put the new um engine on and do the
upgrade that was planned for season six
if they'd have done that in season five
before the end of season 4 after the
zindy conflict I think we'd have got
seven seasons of Enterprise I think it
just needed that little bit of
excitement and a little bit of a boost
to get it through and I actually think
they because they delayed that upgrade
to the Enterprise that's what really
killed the show they needed something
and they missed the
opportunity and another thing Enterprise
had some of the best cast of any of the
St Trek series and I would love to see
Jonathan Archer to Paul flocks whoever
else return in a crossover with strange
new worlds I'm just hoping that season 3
of strange new worlds has a little less
silliness a little less quirky episodes
no bloody
singing and a little bit more Star Trek
to it we can but hope but guys get into
the comments and tell me what you think
because at the end of the day what the
trees actually think is what's important
would you love to see Jonathan archer in
an episode of strange new worlds but
more importantly as well what do you
hope we're going to get from series
three of strange new worlds do you know
where I'm coming from when I say I want
a bit more Star Trek or does that not
make sense to you one maybe two quirky
episodes not three four get in the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think and what you hope for from season
3 of strange new worlds if you are new
to the Channel please like subscribe hit
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to
patreon.com which is where most of our
new videos Premiere first and you get to
see them without the adverts you even
get a free gift after three months can't
say farther than that also go to
s.g. which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
get over and check it out as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time